you know i'm not the i'm not the comic
uh like most comics who started and then
never stopped like once they started
they just
you know i started stop started stop so
it's been a jagged past oh how many i
know you stopped once for two years
how many times do you actually quit i
would say
i fully quit from i started in around
i uh fully quit from about 2 000 to 2005
like two and a half years
um and then i kind of did it often
off and on until i went full in 2008 i
went that's when i started
really uh devoting myself to it quit my
job lived off my girlfriend which by the
way if a lot of young comics
are watching this they say what's what's
one of the big pieces of advice you can
give me one of
is get a girlfriend with a job and have
no shame in having her pay for you
hey okay you got to make some you can't
make homeless without breaking a few
eggs
she is the soldiers that you have to
sacrifice
for the saving private ryan which is
your career
how bad did it get like having to like
live off of someone you're dating like
did it get kind of dicey like giannis
what are you doing here
yeah no she could sense it uh we lived
in a rent control apartment
that my friend grew up when i i'm from
parksville brooklyn so when parks love
guy gentry for it
gentrify gentrify yeah
my my buddy lived in what used to be a
bad area park slope
he moved out so me and my other buddy
renovated his house
by ourselves so what didn't look too
renovated we lived in that rent control
apartment for eight years
we used to hide from the landlord but he
would not because he
you know he he suspected that my friend
wasn't living there whose family was in
his name
and um so she moved in with us my
ex-girlfriend it was me my ex-girlfriend
a roommate
and i think all of our rent was 300 in
park slope brooklyn
when that apartment on the free market
would have went for about 25 hundo
oh my gosh so find a way guys find a way
that's the great thing about comedy is
like
you got to really pave your own road you
can't look at anyone else's road too
much
figure it out that way you have to kind
of uh pave your own
if you love comedy as much as we do here
at hot breath
click the subscribe button to join the
hot breath the verse and then watch more
videos to get even more comedy tips